Welcome to Module 03. We're moving from fully-connected networks to convolutional ones — the architecture that made deep learning practical for images.
The core question: why not just flatten a 224 by 224 image and feed it into a dense layer? Because a single dense layer on that input has 50,000 weights per neuron, and it throws away the spatial structure of the image.
A convolution is a small learnable filter — typically 3 by 3 or 5 by 5 — that slides across the image. Each position computes a weighted sum of the local neighborhood. Same filter, every location. That's weight sharing.
Weight sharing buys you two things: translation equivariance — a cat in the top-left looks the same as a cat in the bottom-right — and parameter efficiency. A 3 by 3 filter has 9 weights, regardless of input size.
Three hyperparameters define a conv layer: kernel size, stride, and padding. Kernel size sets the receptive field. Stride sets the step size. Padding determines whether the output shrinks or stays the same size as the input.
The output shape formula is worth memorizing: output equals floor of input minus kernel plus two times padding, divided by stride, plus one. We'll use this every time we debug a shape mismatch, which is often.
Pooling layers — max pool and average pool — reduce spatial dimensions without learnable parameters. Max pool is the classic: take the largest value in each 2 by 2 window. It's translation-robust and cheap.
The receptive field grows as you stack layers. After two 3 by 3 convs, each output pixel sees a 5 by 5 region of the input. After three, 7 by 7. Depth trades computation for context.
LeNet-5, from 1998, established the template: conv, pool, conv, pool, dense, dense. It ran on 32 by 32 handwritten digits. The ideas were right; the hardware wasn't yet.
AlexNet in 2012 was the phase change. Eight layers, ReLU instead of sigmoid, dropout, data augmentation, and two GPUs. It halved the ImageNet error rate overnight. Deep learning's ImageNet moment.
VGG, in 2014, went deeper — 16 and 19 layers — with only 3 by 3 convolutions. The insight: two stacked 3 by 3 convs have the same receptive field as one 5 by 5 conv, but with fewer parameters and more non-linearity.
ResNet in 2015 broke the depth barrier with residual connections. Instead of learning a direct mapping, each block learns a residual — the delta from identity. Suddenly networks of 50, 101, even 152 layers trained cleanly.
The reason residuals work: gradients flow backward through the identity path without being multiplied by layer weights. Vanishing gradients stop being the bottleneck. Optimization becomes well-behaved.
Beyond ResNet: Inception uses parallel filter sizes. DenseNet concatenates all previous feature maps. EfficientNet scales depth, width, and resolution together. Each trades parameters for a different inductive bias.
Vision Transformers, or ViTs, take a radically different approach. They split the image into patches, treat each patch as a token, and apply a transformer. No convolutions at all. With enough data, they match or beat CNNs.
So which architecture should you use? Short answer: start with a pretrained ResNet-50 or EfficientNet-B0 and fine-tune. You almost never want to train a vision model from scratch. Transfer learning dominates in practice.
Transfer learning means: take a model pretrained on ImageNet's 1.2 million images, strip the final classifier, and attach a new head for your task. Freeze the backbone at first, then unfreeze gradually.
The lab this week builds exactly that pipeline: load a pretrained backbone from Keras Applications, freeze it, attach a GlobalAveragePooling and Dense head, train on CIFAR-10 or a small custom dataset, then fine-tune.
Watch two numbers during training: top-1 accuracy and validation loss. If validation loss starts climbing while training loss keeps dropping, you're overfitting — enable augmentation, add dropout, or freeze earlier layers.
Data augmentation is essentially free regularization for images. Random flips, crops, rotations, color jitter, and cutout or mixup — all standard. Keras has a preprocessing layer for most of these that runs on the GPU.
Feature visualization is how you convince yourself the network learned something real. Early filters respond to edges and colors; middle layers to textures and parts; late layers to objects. We'll visualize all three in the lab.
One last thing: batch normalization. It's placed between conv and activation in most modern CNNs. It normalizes activations per mini-batch, which stabilizes training and lets you use higher learning rates. It has quirks — remember to set training equals false at inference.
Common failure modes we'll cover: shape mismatches from wrong padding, stagnant loss from a frozen learning rate, exploding activations from missing batchnorm, and silent accuracy drops from a misaligned preprocessing pipeline.
By the end of this module you'll have trained a CNN from scratch on a small dataset, fine-tuned a pretrained backbone on a larger one, visualized internal features, and diagnosed at least two shape bugs — the authentic deep learning rite of passage.
Next module, we'll layer on advanced training techniques — schedulers, optimizers, regularization, and mixed precision — the toolkit that separates a model that trains from a model that trains well.
Housekeeping: all lab notebooks pin TensorFlow 2.18 and Keras 3.7. If you see API mismatches, check the pinned versions in requirements.txt before assuming the tutorial is wrong. Module 03, let's go.